you can't make things up like this  foreign  [Music]  that's what it seems like okay  that's what it looks like  uh because they're here right  and if they don't get fuel they'll  freeze  i mean this is like  this is like from one human to another  [Music]  oh  oh you're refusing now are you  [Music]  you're not a soldier you're a dwell  no  [Music]  are we going  we're here to make everyone safe  to make sure that people that are here  protesting  are our voices are heard  that's what we want justin trudeau  doesn't want to hear nothing  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  okay  [Music]  remember  we don't forget you people turn your  back on humanity in canada he's  disgusting  shameful  shame on you  we have your trials for you all you know  well i saw her today at the  manifestation  [Music]  a glass of wine  i knew that she was gonna meet  her connections  right now you're being detained  what are you being arrested for you're  wonderful  being arrested what's the charge  please